hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do
another dark season3 video about some of
the theories that are popping up and
some of the ideas that are out there
after the trailer dropped there was also
some additional new footage that got
released on the German Netflix channel
after I had already started editing my
first video it's really interesting so
we'll take a look at that as well I'm
also gonna talk about some of the behind
the scenes photos that have been posted
on Instagram like I did in my season 3
spoilers video from last year that means
there will be spoilers and of course
I'll be discussing everything that's
happened in dark in the first two
seasons if any of that raises red flags
for you now is your chance to leave as
for the additional footage we see this
new trio again in some of the same shots
we saw from the teaser I still tend to
think this is happening in the past
based on the lanterns they're carrying
but we did also see these guys out in
the world in the 80s one of the things I
didn't touch on before is that the Sikh
Munda Slayer looks abandoned and it
makes us wonder where Adam traveled
after the apocalypse it also calls into
question where the rest of Sikh moondust
are especially the older Magnus and
Francisco and then we get a shot of old
Helga and he has an injury to his eye
rather than his ear this seems like a
pretty good indication that he is alt
Helga of alt Martha's world just like
the way we see Martha has a different
haircut and magnus has a different hair
color and tattoos alt Helga is saying
tick tock tick tock much in the same way
he did in the wind and we already know
this hints that he was involved with
Time Traveller's in both worlds after
that we get a shot outside the caves
with alt versions of our Tosh Magnus
Francisca and Marta we also see another
teenager with the gang that's
conspicuously missing Jonas and Mikkel
the new character is an actor who had a
small role in Martha's play in season
one and he showed up in a lot of the
behind the scenes photos based on old
Claudia's statement that she's seen the
world without Jonas we expect that he
was never born in this world Marta is
wearing the yellow raincoat which makes
us think that she is the onus is
replacement in this world and then
new character is probably just a friend
from high school to fill out the group
the teens are all carrying flashlights
and we see them turn towards the cave
like they're startled by a sound inside
we can only speculate on what's going on
here but since they're startled by a
sound someone may be traveling through
the passage then we get what is probably
the most interesting shop for me we see
a workshop in the past where stranger
yonas is working on something what's
really crazy about this is that Altmark
a is standing behind him and we get a
close-up shot to confirm it's her this
appears to be in the distant past and
there was a clear shot of this on
instagram that makes it seem pretty
certain that he's working on the god
particle twin machine under the church
the big question is what does alt Marta
being there actually mean obviously she
saved the onus when he was younger but
this looks like the stranger
post-apocalypse if he's working under
what will eventually be the church it's
safe to say he's accepted his path in
founding SiC Mundus and ultimately
becoming Adam Marta looks different than
she did in the season 2 finale and there
were some shots from filming that were
posted that were captioned with the
question a new look for Marta which kind
of draw a distinction from the Marta we
saw at the end of the season after
thinking about this the shot of the
letter burning in the teaser came to
mind young no it did say it was written
by Marta which wouldn't make sense if he
was talking about Marta prime the
popular theories were that atom wrote it
himself or that it had to be sent by alt
Marta seeing these two characters
together at this point makes me lean
towards it being the latter and that
could add an interesting layer if she
was warning him about the trio either
way these two interacted beyond her
saving his life during stranger Jonases
transformation into atom so the letter
could come from her and atom could have
given it to noah beyond that the german
teaser is mostly just recycled shots but
there is this one of the onus that's
slightly different and we get a better
look at those golden lights which seem
to be tied to travelling between worlds
we saw them in the other teaser when
Claudia used the golden or the travel
hell did showing up does confirm my
guess that it was him in the shot and
the teaser and as mentioned the scar on
his
I confirms he's an aunt version did he
get this scar by being bashed in the
head with the rock - we don't know yet
but there was this shot of a woman
bashing someone and right it has
identified who she is this photo of a
bloody woman with an 80s looking pink
jacket has been up on Baron bow Oh DARS
website for a while this actor played a
minor role in season 2 as the nurse in
the facility where Alric is currently
growing old the character's name is
Helene Wolfe which doesn't connect her
to anything I can think of I imagine
that this is similar to the new teenager
and that they used an actor who had a
small part in previous seasons to play
something different in the alternate
world if that's the case she could be
assaulting alt Helga but there's some
problems with that first the shot is
purposely cut so we can't see who she's
hitting and also in the prime world
Helga was a boy in the 1950s and her
clothing doesn't match that when I saw
where this was I thought about Hannah
because of the theory about the woman in
the lake I talked about this theory in
my spoilers video which stems from Bart
Oz's story while they were swimming in
the lake in season 2 episode 6 remember
we saw in photos that Hannah who's in
1954 is wearing the st. Christopher
pendant when it's brand new
she appears to be the first owner in
years later
yonis and Marta will find the pendant on
the shore the lake is the only common
denominator here though it's hard to
connect the dots so that it makes sense
that Hannah is bludgeoned to death in
the 80s by a minor character and then
later the legend becomes a woman in a
dress drowned in the lake that doesn't
mean this isn't Hannah or that this
isn't how the pendant ended up there but
if that's the case the woman in the lake
theory would be wrong people also think
Helene wolf could be Caterina's mother
based off of this photo there is a woman
behind the teen and a pink coat hanging
there
I'm not sure though I mean the evidence
is pretty weak but there were a lot of
pictures of teen Katarina on the
Instagram account so we're likely to
learn more about her the problem was
speculating on that is that we don't
know what that'll be connected to for me
the most compelling mystery from all
this new footage remains who are the
trio I stand by my thinking that they
our brand-new characters that we haven't
met before but there are a lot of
theories out there that disagree with me
the ones I see repeated the most are
that it's the real Alexander Kohler or
alt world's mad Nielsen but I've also
seen people who think it might be Peter
or even a child of Jonas an alt Marta
the Mads theory seems to hinge on a
resemblance between the child actors who
play them which doesn't really convince
me
Mads role in the story was to give
Ulrich a personal history that makes him
question a connection when kids start to
go missing again I don't really see how
an alt version of him becoming these
characters would be a bonus
the Alexander angle also is based on the
resemblance of the middle character in
the picture of Klaus ins brother and the
question of why Boris knew Walt took his
identity is a more compelling mystery
that needs to be explained again the
evidence here doesn't really get me
excited
the trio all have this cleft lip that
connects them and none of the photos
that exists of the original Alexander
Koehler have that for me Boris knee wall
who later becomes the central character
Alexander Tiedemann is the more
interesting part of that mystery it's
not to say that these theories aren't
possible because certainly they are and
they are popular I just haven't jumped
on board with any that I've read to this
point and I'm not trying to be glib
there are other pieces of circumstantial
evidence that pop up to support these
ideas if you use them as your starting
point
things like Mads being sacrificed by SiC
moon dust in the prime world because of
his importance elsewhere based on what
we've seen though these guys give me a
vibe that says that they're from
somewhere else they are three versions
of the same person 33 years apart in age
that operate as one we see them destroy
the lair under the church which is
essentially SiC moon das's collection of
time-travel knowledge and they seem to
be intervening in a way that shows they
know what's going on one of the theories
I've seen is that they are from a third
world which could be related to the
Trinity not imagery that sort of
naturally builds off the infinity symbol
imagery representing the two worlds
connected to each other I've even seen
people go as far as to say that they are
from the world without time which Adam
has said he wants to create but I think
it's too early too
tell I do wonder if these guys might be
behind the triquetra notebook since its
origin is still a mystery but it's a
leap to get there from watching 25
seconds of them in a trailer the other
thing I decided not to bring up is this
idea of Adam and Eve I actually started
writing about it but found myself going
in circles because the idea brings up
more questions than it answers for me
the gist is that in the world where
Jonas doesn't exist
Martha leads a life similar to his where
she grows old to become Eve after all if
we have someone who changed his name to
Adam and hangs around with this guy
whose name he changed to Noah well then
why not have an Eve especially when you
have a character in a room that looks an
awful lot like the sick moon the Slayer
except that it has a painting of Adam
and Eve on the wall instead of the fall
of the Damned not to mention the first
time the character shows up she's
carrying a time machine more advanced
than anything that we've seen that also
happens to resemble an Apple Plus in the
casting news we had an actor who could
be used to portray and Eve that is 33
years older than alt Marta beyond these
obvious connections I'm just left with a
bunch of questions I can't answer yes it
does seem like in the alt world Martha
has a past similar to Yona tsa's in the
prime world but why why does this world
exist in the first place
is it occurring naturally has it always
existed or is it a result of time travel
in the first place if it's a product of
that then are we dealing with a universe
where when something happens that
affects the past a new timeline or
branch then exists we don't really know
at this point because we've been
presented with a deterministic system
where nothing could be changed
plus there's a whole bunch of other
things like you have to ask are Adam and
Eve working together or are they enemies
how does Claudia fit into that picture
and it just keeps going from there
there's also this much repeated idea
floating around about the tic-tock
voiceover at the end of the trailer it
goes tick-tock then talk tick and then
just talk the idea is that things go in
Reverse in the alt world as in literally
in Reverse like the shots in the trailer
of Jonah's running backwards and Martha
with the tear running up her
face so you would have the prime world
where things go one way
Marta's world where things go the other
way and then the final talk would be a
representation of a world where time
doesn't exist everything in the alt
world playing in Reverse seems
completely impractical from a viewing
perspective though and the shots of alt
helga and the cave from the German
Netflix video aren't presented that way
they go forward I mean call me
old-fashioned but I sort of expect that
scenes including dialogue would be
presented in a way that we can easily
understand what's happening so in the
end I'm curious about how these worlds
exist how they are connected and what it
all means but I don't think we have the
answers and honestly I like it that way
and with that I will bring this video to
an end let me know in the comments what
you think about what we've seen of dark
season 3 so far and which of these
theories get your wheels turning and let
me know what kind of dark videos you'd
like to see in the coming month while we
wait for the season to draw please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon